Answer this question: What
matters more to you than money?
Now ask yourself: Why?
Those are your values.
Hey, everyone.
I'm Elaine Welteroth, and
I'm the editor-in-chief
of "Teen Vogue."
I spent over a decade building
a career as a magazine editor.
It's really scary to
walk away from that.
I looked up one day and
realized that I had more dreams.
Gone are the days we work at one
company for our entire lives.
It's about dreaming
out of the box
and designing a career path
that's as unique as you are.
This MasterClass is for all
the creative entrepreneurs,
the multi-hyphenates,
which I like
to call "moguls in the
making", big dreamers who
just need a little bit
of help figuring out
how to map out
exactly how you're
going to make all of
your career dreams
happen in this one lifetime.
We're going to talk about the
difference between good writing
and great writing, marketing
and social media, team building.
It takes a village, y'all.
What is your zone of genius?
That sweet spot at
the intersection
of your passions, talents,
values, and your skills.
Understanding your
zone of genius
allows you to stay focused
on what matters the most.
It is never too late to pivot.
Fear is going to be
part of the process.
You're thinking, "How am
I going to pay my bills?
What about health
insurance, girl?
I'm tired of ramen noodles."
I've been there.
I completely get it.
We have to figure out
how to dance with fear
to be able to reinvent ourselves
and our careers time and time
again, and I want to
help you craft the plan
to make it happen.
I'm Elaine Welteroth, and
this is my MasterClass.